oh hey guess what sitting down now
[ __ ] happy
all these taco why is he standing why is
he standing that's what it's [ __ ]
healthy look at that
you can't tell me what to do
can't [ __ ] with the system here we go
and yeah [ __ ] not hey hey oh hey hey
I don't have any [ __ ] health
any [ __ ] healing oh my god oh my god
oh my god goddamn he's tough
[ __ ] this
we play game
gotcha [ __ ] hey we're in the forest hey
we got a little wolfies hey how you
doing Betty oh my god what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna go get it go nap I'm gonna go
you'll never find me here Oh God [ __ ]
you calm down just calm down
oh my god just chill man ugly trash all
right here and surprise [ __ ]
look at him
he wants me you want some of the oh
that's right yeah this red baby yeah
dark soon oh I'm a lie I'm a [ __ ]
live I'm a [ __ ] live zero - oh hey
girl how you doing just chillin in the
forest just up holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] so
casual I never seen anyone so casually
in my life I want that [ __ ] sword
it's [ __ ] badass what are you throwing
at oranges what an [ __ ]
surprise [ __ ] Oh get [ __ ] on and
your oranges stick them up your ass oh
[ __ ] yeah we're using this weapon from
now on fist oh my god I cut his [ __ ]
ass off oh where do I go I'm so lost
then rather Oh God Oh God
down there on death yeah there are death
all right I'm going to inhale all of
this helium in my system and I'm going
to kill myself
Sarah - this does not mean the end one
death one damn god [ __ ] one that
doesn't sound as good a zero dead
does that [ __ ] me we're just gonna go
for it
yo lost a baby hey look it's a little oh
my god what that spot
J says [ __ ] Christ [ __ ] hell doctor
crabbers put on some [ __ ] weight I
think this is actually where we were
supposed to go hi everybody
markiplier here
no no no no no let me out let me out let
me out let me the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you what the [ __ ] is that
put the [ __ ] piss crystals kind of
[ __ ] vape that I vape man Jesus Jesus
Jesus
Jason Jason Jade son the [ __ ] why are
their crystals butch what the [ __ ] are
you then oh my lord baby
Ethan Barry Barry where are you [ __ ] oh
god it was a fake it was a fake it was
an Ethan Bradberry oh my god there's
nobody in the red berries right Ethan
Bradberry
it'd be boring
even
oh my god [ __ ] [ __ ]
Navaro see jab help me Jesus
[ __ ] ass what is that that is
literally Jesus oh my god sorry I didn't
know what the [ __ ] are you doing here
Jesus head in the back okay well that's
just great
you're not any night
what do you call that move being an
[ __ ] oh god it's over that is
literally a black night [ __ ] me I can't
beat that but I shave asses
oh my [ __ ] god what just happen oh my
god this is a mushroom what is this a
[ __ ] table what am I looking at you I
think we can do the boss like I don't
know what else - [ __ ] exploring this
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] area here we go
that was pretty [ __ ] good start
wasn't it done Ethan Bradberry I'm Ethan
Bradberry I'm Ethan Bradberry oh my god
better than Ethan Bradberry buy me some
bread some even bread better than me the
mayor where the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
suck all the [ __ ] poop out Cheryl
gasps you want to shave too mom
you want to [ __ ] shave that's how
it's done baby
mushroom hat
alright that was another episode of dank
souls I hope you bros enjoy a lot of
time and effort goes into these if you
would be so kind leave a like I really
appreciate it and as always stay awesome
brush